it's been a bad year for big Tech
we're used to seeing companies like
apple Amazon Google and meta at the very
top of the global corporate ladder but
the economic headwinds of 2022 have hit
the sector hard
[Music]
yes absolutely this year has been really
really painful for tech stocks when
macroeconomic conditions and the
products themselves kind of reach a
certain age then things calm down and
sometimes there's a bust
as well as a shaky economy the world's
biggest companies have also been
grappling with increased regulatory
scrutiny and legal challenges from
Beijing to Brussels
the European commission has been using
its existing competition powers and to
Target what they perceive as potentially
abusive conduct by the largest digital
platforms you know the economic
fundamentals of these companies have
families
you know be threatened by this Crackdown
so is the party over in this video we'll
ask if this is just a bump in the road
for big Tech or a full-blown existential
crisis there is a season for all of
these Technologies and particularly with
consumer facing products consumers are
fickle you know we move on
it's all coming up on business Beyond
as you've probably already gathered
we'll be using the term big Tech quite a
lot in this video but what exactly does
it mean
big Tech typically refers to the most
dominant firms in the information
technology sector that usually means the
U.S tech Giants
alphabet which is Google Amazon Apple
meta formerly known as Facebook and
Microsoft
the big and the name refers to both
their market value and the often Mammoth
scale of their operations when we're
talking about tech big Tech what I mean
by that is what would be what we'd refer
to as Mega cap
stocks so those are those companies
um you know brushing on the or have at
least touched on the trillion dollar
valuation at some point in their in
their life
only a handful of companies meet that
criteria all of them in the US
they dominate the internet and most
areas of digital Commerce
from search to social media
and from online retail to computers and
smartphones big Tech is the shorthand
for the small number of mostly consumer
facing companies based in the Bay Area
and Seattle in the west coast of the
United States
Microsoft Amazon Apple meta and uh
what am I missing Google
these companies are commonly referred to
as the big five but others such as the
streaming service Netflix electric car
maker Tesla and the chipmaker Nvidia are
also occasionally included that's why
there's a wide range of acronyms
associated with big Tech combining
letters from some or all of the
companies
the rise of several Chinese Tech Giants
in recent years means they are also
increasingly part of the big Tech
conversation
[Music]
China is the only country other than the
United States that have so far been able
to Foster attack Giants so in terms of
market capitalization you know companies
like Alibaba 10 cents
they're among the top 10 uh Tech uh Tech
farms in the world
but mostly big tech means the five firms
we listed at the beginning
before we take a deeper look at some of
the difficulties these companies have
been experiencing it's worth reminding
ourselves just how much they've come to
dominate Global business and our
personal lives in such a short space of
time
until relatively recently the world's
most valuable companies came from
industrial and energy sectors
Microsoft is the exception it's been one
of the most valuable for more than 25
years and in 2010 was joined in the
world's top five by Apple
today big Tech firms are dominant four
of the world's current top five most
valuable companies come from the sector
namely Apple Amazon alphabet and
Microsoft
Silicon Valley has a long history but
really the last 20 years has stood apart
in the scale and the speed and how did
these companies become so large in part
because they started doing more things
and coming into more areas of life not
just a device that sits on one's desk
that's useful for work or for school but
a you know platforms that and apps that
facilitate all sorts of things experts
like Margaret O'Mara argue that the key
to the astonishing rides of big Tech is
something which you may well be holding
in your hand right now
the smartphone I think a really
important
um enabler of this was the smartphone uh
particularly the iPhone and and then
following that the Android Google
Android phone which all and all the apps
that were built for that think about
Uber and Lyft or Airbnb or these
companies that really are made possible
by uh cell phone use and or having a
device that you're carrying with you
that has enabled the scale up in an
extraordinary way another thing which
has enabled the scale up is an
unprecedented amount of money a decade
of record low interest rates has been a
huge boost to Big Tech
since the global financial crisis there
has been a quantitative easing by
central banks in the U.S and elsewhere
there's been a great deal of money
sloshing around the financial system
with wealthy people looking to invest in
the stock market and Tech has been a
really really alluring that and so a lot
of money has come into companies both
public and private in this sector
means we have well and truly been living
in the age of big Tech
since 2006 the annual revenues of the
leading firms have swelled to
eye-watering levels
since the financial crisis the
accumulation of profits has accelerated
with apple and Amazon supplanting
Microsoft in the race for top spot now
Amazon Apple and Google routinely break
in hundreds of billions of dollars per
year in Revenue helping to explain why
these companies are valued in the
trillion dollar range
so what could possibly go wrong
plenty if this here is anything to go by
throughout 2022 and particularly in
recent months tech stocks have lost a
lot of value take a look at this graphic
showing the performance of so-called FFA
and G stocks which includes Netflix
since August
meta Amazon Apple and Google have all
suffered significant losses in value
with companies like meta losing as much
as 40 in the space of a few months
Netflix did perform markedly better as
it rolled out a new ad-based
subscription model
in one week alone at the end of October
close to 800 billion dollars was wiped
off the value of the biggest U.S tech
companies a big reason is the same one
that helped make these companies so big
in the first place interest rates
Rising interest rates are a reflection
of a global economy struggling on
multiple fronts fueling uncertainty
around stocks which had at times looked
Invincible more highly valued companies
or growth stocks as you might have heard
them called and are particularly
sensitive to Rising interest rates
because what happens is investors are no
longer kind of convinced to take on the
risk of investing in individual more
expensive quote-unquote expensive
companies because they can get better
rates on their savings so that's one big
reason people don't want to be investing
in stocks that they do as highly valued
and that's why Tech has been
particularly
um hard hit
um this year it's a it's a mixture of
those dynamics of higher interest rates
and then kind of the the risk profile
that investors are prepared to take as
well as broader really huge economic
uncertainty but while all these
companies are broadly grouped together
as Tech they're on very different
businesses for those reliant on
Advertising Revenue news such as Mata
the company behind household social
media Brands like Facebook WhatsApp and
Instagram the pain has been more acute
we saw that Revenue last quarter was
down four percent and that was because
of a drop in advertising revenue and
there's a few things going on at play
there one of the things is that the
price per ad was down 18 so that's
really Stark that to me tells me that
just more broadly the advertising space
and convincing marketing teams to cart
with their cash for the economic
um environment is so uncertain is really
really difficult but also there's a
question is it that we're seeing
Facebook and Instagram are actually
losing their potency you know there's a
lot of competition for eyeballs nowadays
is Tick Tock more of a threat than it
used to be things like that while most
businesses are vulnerable in a weak
economy the turbulence and Tech is
leading to some fundamental questions
about the future for some of these
companies
that's especially true of matter
anticipating a shift in social media
habits its CEO Mark Zuckerberg has
placed a big bet on the concept of a 3D
virtual reality metaverse his company is
investing billions into what remains an
unproven concept there's a lot of
potential there but unfortunately
getting it off the ground is
astronomically expensive and the group's
actually just upped to what it plans to
spend and that wasn't taken very well by
the market because what people are
seeing is actually you're pouring money
into an unproven concept and there's not
really any stringent plans around how
things are going to to work but it's not
just bets on the future that are putting
off investors many experts are
attributing big Tech's current
difficulties to decisions made to expand
during the pandemic when lockdowns
around the world led to a digital boom
particularly in the area of e-commerce
while the companies are enormous and
they became in the last two years during
the coronavirus pandemic had this
extraordinary scale up even beyond what
they had imagined before
um point of reference both meta and
Amazon doubled their workforces since
February 2020. the Amazon is really
struggling at the moment there's no two
ways about it you know of course we lost
three billion dollars last last course
so that's not something that you can
just ignore and the reason that that's
happened is that the group spent
massively on building its fulfillment
um capacity over over the pandemic when
you know we saw that huge boom and
online shopping I know I was I was
guilty of that seeing the sofa ordering
everything
um but the problem is now is that demand
isn't matching that scale so customers
are looking for value they're not buying
Big Ticket items they're only buying
what they have to and for something like
Amazon and that is really really going
to hurt Amazon and meta are two of
several Tech Giants to have laid off
tens of thousands of workers so far this
year so the layoffs we're seeing from
those two companies as well as many
other companies in recent weeks has been
in in many ways are right sizing a kind
of there was so much growth and it was
anticipating that it was responding to
these very extraordinary circumstances
of 2020 in which so many of their users
were at home relying on a delivery of
groceries to your doorstep or
communication by by computer only
and now that things have gone back to a
late covid post-covered world that
demand's gone so you don't need all
those people anymore but it's not just
economic pressures which have put the
squeeze on big Tech
in recent years firms like meta Google
and apple have faced mounting legal
challenges on issues ranging from
privacy to antitrust
the European commission which is the
executive arm of the EU has been leading
the charge it has taken on the likes of
Apple on its tax arrangements and has
increasingly been challenging the market
dominance of the world's biggest firms
in particular Google
the European commission has been using
its existing competition powers
to Target what they perceive as
potentially abusive conduct by the
largest digital Platforms in particular
Google has been hit by three separate
decisions in relation to Google shopping
which is concerned it's search engine
Google Android which concerned its
mobile operating system and then Google
AdSense which confirmed concerned its
advertising business model and all of
those are part of a wider Trend where
there is a perception by Regulators in
particular the European commission
that's some of the conduct of the
largest digital platforms has caused
harm to European markets and in
particular has harmed outcomes for
consumers as well as smaller businesses
that some some degree reliant on their
services many of the eu's challenges are
still ongoing including cases against
Apple Amazon and meta but the commission
recently introduced a signature piece of
legislation called the digital markets
act which it hopes will deal more
efficiently with antitrust issues in the
future
so the digital markets Act is a piece of
legislation that seeks to increase
fairness and contestability for the
largest digital Platforms in the EU a
lot of these American but they're not
just American platforms and and what it
does is it imposes a series of set rules
that are designed to open up some parts
of the digital ecosystem in other parts
to ensure that there's more fairness for
their business users and also to ensure
that end consumers so the likes of me
and you me and you have better rights
vis-a-vis Gatekeepers or all with the
objective of ultimately ensuring that
markets work better
the digital markets act in particular is
likely to force the world's biggest Tech
firms to make big changes to how they
operate in Europe and elsewhere but it
may not necessarily mean they will
become smaller it is certainly expected
that their business models will be
changed but I wouldn't necessarily draw
a kind of a straight line between saying
okay there's intervention by competition
Regulators here and that will inevitably
mean that the largest platforms become
smaller and in many ways that may not be
a good outcome what we want to see is
effectively better Market outcomes for
all consumers so that we effectively
deliver better output better quality
products and also more Innovation so
that smaller players and big Tech
players can innovate together for what's
coming next because in some ways it's
all very well regulating what's happened
over the last decade but what you're
really trying to do is make sure that
your regulatory regime works for the
decades to come another country where
there has been a huge regulatory
backlash against big Tech is China
when the billionaire businessman Jack ma
strongly criticized Chinese Financial
Regulators in a speech he made in
October 2020 it directly led to the
suspension of the IPO of his company and
group
[Music]
it then prompted an unprecedented
Crackdown on some of the country's
leading Tech firms
[Music]
leadership mobilized
I've never seen before against the big
tech companies which array affect a wide
range of sectors like e-commerce brow
handling social media gaming tutoring
you know almost everything you can think
think of now
um to summarize what has happened we can
broadly see the law enforcement in three
major pillars one is antitrust the other
is data and Then followed by labor
regulations
few if any major Chinese Tech firms have
been left untouched
Commerce giant Alibaba was fined 2.8
billion dollars in an Anti-Trust case
while food delivery platform metuan was
also targeted then in the summer of 2021
the ride hailing platform DD was given a
fine of more than one billion dollars
for data security breaches
beginning of 2022 the Crackdown has been
eased significantly
partly because of concerns over economic
damage we started to see things slow
down begins this year and partly because
China had experienced a economic
slowdown and earlier this year there was
a massive sell of China's internet
stocks in the United States so the
economic uncertainty in instability
touch a sensitive nerve of the Chinese
top leadership and that's why you see in
March this year the vice premium premium
meeting sending a very strong signal
that China is going to ease regulation
in a way to calm the investors
but a lot of damage has already been
done to China's big Tech firms
a lost over 50 percent of the market
valuations
um as well as many other Tech Farms
probably even more like in the case of
DD and investors a particularly
International investors have very severe
concern about investing in the Chinese
Tech sector so to the extent that if you
think you know having sufficient Capital
injected in injected into the Chinese
market is essential for the growth and
development of of the Chinese tag that
certainly does not go very well so far
in this episode we've looked at some of
the biggest challenges faced by the
world's Tech Giants
but what is not yet clear is whether
recent events fundamentally Challenge
and threaten those firms Global
dominance
some of the companies such as Apple and
Google most experts agree their
dominance will continue given the power
of their brands and how embedded they
have become in the lives of so many
people
the point of Brazilian
Village Assets in a high inflationary
environment because it means that even
though yes people are struggling with
their incomes if your brand is strong
enough you're still going to encourage a
high proportion of people to smash the
cash on your products every innovator
can't be an innovator forever but that
doesn't mean these companies will proof
disappear I think they've become too big
I think they've become too embedded
their products are in many so many
places and embedded that it doesn't just
vanish overnight
yet the sense that the tectonic plates
underneath big Tech are shifting after
15 years of Relentless growth is
undeniable the great hope of all these
Silicon Valley venture capitalists and
antec people who are interested in the
next generation of Technology are like
what's next what's going to be the next
thing
um and there have been some efforts to
kind of make web 3 the next thing and
cryptocurrency the next thing and uh and
then this kind of amorphous AI which
really is an enormous category of course
artificial intelligence is going to be a
thing but what's the use case like
what's the platform what's going to be
necessary finding that next big thing
may be critical to the longer term
viability of some of the world's biggest
Tech firms some could slip out of view
and others which we may not have even
heard of yet will take their place
but even if it is a big Tech World we're
all living in now the events of 2022
have shown that no one's players at the
top can be taken for granted
that's all from this edition of business
Beyond
if you'd like to see more from us check
out our playlist a great place to start
would be our recent video on how the
next Global recession could be very
different from the last one thanks a lot
for watching and until the next time
take care
foreign
[Music]